on this giving tuesday many non-profits
in our community are asking for your
donations and one of those is
family promise of las vegas kirsten
joyce joining us now
from home to tell us more about what
they do and their very unique fundraiser
kicking off today
brian family promise of las vegas has
been helping families at risk for
homelessness for nearly 25 years in
clark county
they've seen almost a 400 percent
increase in the knee during this
pandemic
they've helped more than 500 families to
date since march
today the nonprofit kicked off its
month-long virtual fundraiser called
heart of home
by going to their website they're asking
you to make a donation a contribution
and then post a photo and a line of what
home means to you
you can click the mosaic to see what
others have posted
we recently were able to help save one
of the dancers from one of the shows
save his home he had gone through all of
his money all of his savings
and came to us for assistance to save
his home
we were able to do that and uh and that
made me feel really good
listening to the executive director
there now it's great to see what others
have posted on the mosaic the heart of
home mosaic
website pictures of their family members
of their dogs things like that
this will last through december 31st and
if you can't give this year you can
still go on the mosaic and check it out
and see what people are sharing denise
kirsten that's a great effort well life